bom dia a todos pra quem não me conhece
meu nome é flávio tonidandel tenho
aproximadamente em 20 anos aí
trabalhando e pesquisando na área de
inteligência artificial e robótica e
gostaria de falar um pouco com vocês
sobre o avanço da inteligência
artificial e na área há ainda a nossa
sociedade
bom a eu vou relacionar inteligência
artificial que o comportamento humano e
principalmente analisar quais são as
nossas expectativas com relação à
inteligência artificial é natural a
gente imaginar que a inteligência
artificial vai mexer muito com a nossa
vida nós escutamos isso todos os dias e
com as suas nossas reais expectativas
com relação à inteligência artificial
bom quando a gente fala inteligência
artificial a primeira coisa que vem à
nossa cabeça é o big data a inteligência
social está fazendo isso com as empresas
ela coleta dados analisa os dados e
apresenta novas sugestões novas decisões
ou auxilia os empresários a tomarem
melhor ea entender melhor o seu negócio
tomar melhores decisões
ok bom mas em inteligência fiscal é
muito mais do que isso
quando a gente fala inteligência
artificial a gente está falando num um
algoritmo ou num programa que aprendi
com o ser humano
a gente está falando de um algoritmo que
pode tomar decisões para você
e não estamos falando de um algoritmo
que pode transformar de vez toda essa
nossa sociedade
bom a inteligência artificial
principalmente a aqui vêm os nossos
aplicativos nossos celulares
ela vem estender a nossa vida assim como
a gente não consegue mais viver sem o
smartphone em breve a gente não vai
conseguir viver mais em inteligência
artificial isso em alguns momentos pode
ser assustador mas a se você pensar que
a inteligência artificial vem para
melhorar nossa vida ela começa a gente
começa a ter uma certa dependência desse
sistema inteligente e aí a gente chega
ao ponto
deixou se está aqui é bom não está
andando
é o que vai acontecer é que a
inteligência social vai chegar até o que
a gente chama de cidades independentes
então imagina esse cenário você acorda
de manhã a você tenha 11 no seu celular
ou talvez o seu assistente pessoal pode
ser um robô pode ser um dispositivo ao
lado da sua cama
ele acorda ele avisa vai ser sua agenda
ele te passa todos os detalhes de como
vai ser a sua vida naquele momento
além disso ele vai chegar e falar olha o
robô já preparou a sua comida já está
seguindo a sua dieta
a gente já pegou com o seu médico que a
gente já sabe exatamente o que comer no
dia anterior o que você precisa comer no
dia de hoje
bom você prepara essa você vai tomar seu
café da manhã já chega um um casulo
talvez um carro autônomo menor não tem a
pessoa não tem ninguém dirigindo
isso já está integrado com todo o
sistema de transporte você não precisa
mais ficar descendo do seu casulo
esperar o trem chegar ou você não
precisa mais do que sair e entrar no
aeroporto fazer check in
tudo integrado e tudo controlado pela
inteligência artificial porque eu tô
falando tudo isso existe um
um detalhe importante aí quando a gente
fala de sistemas inteligentes é que o
sistema vai aprender com você e quando a
gente fala isso para a gente imagina que
isso é uma coisa natural inteligência
silva e observar o que a gente faz e vai
tentar repetir o que a gente faz
vai aprender com a gente há como se
comportar
há como resolver os problemas e aí entra
uma questão crucial
aí vai ter que aprender a resolver
dilemas vai ter que aprender se ética aí
vai ter que aprender a lidar com
situações que nós seres humanos não lhe
damos muito bem e isso pode ser um
gargalo é enorme
o desenvolvimento da inteligência
artificial só para vocês verem como isso
pode ser um pouco assustador a imagina
se que a inteligência social pode chegar
a níveis diz de controlar grandes
empresas tão grande se ou de uma empresa
vai ser um sistema de inteligência
artificial
toda vez que eu falo isso empresários
olham pra mim falando você tá ficando
louco mas prestem atenção e inteligência
fiscal já comanda sua vida de alguma
forma você usa o aplicativo de
roteamento de de trânsito você usa
aplicativos de música que sugerem
músicas pra você e ele está aprendendo
conforme o seu comportamento e nós
estamos usando nós estamos usando isso
achando muito legal
nós gostamos disso porque nós não vamos
gostar de um senhor de inteligência
artificial pode ser que ele chega na
empresa falou dado o comportamento que
eu estou analisando de todo de todo
mundo eu vou tomar essa decisão não é só
nossa que legal
o senhor humano não tinha essa percepção
aí a tem então ela pode ser realmente
boa
nós temos que tomar cuidado com algumas
coisas
uma delas é o dilema moral aqui tem um
tem um site só foi uma pesquisa
realizada e tem resultados bem
interessantes que é sobre um carro
autônomo e de repente ele perdeu o freio
se ele não consegue parar o carro tem
tomar algumas decisões
se vocês fizerem esse teste vocês vão
ver o quanto é difícil tomar algumas
decisões
o teste é bem perspicaz no sentido de
tentar extrair do ser humano qual seria
a decisão dele é você no volante se você
perdesse o controle do carro tivesse que
decidir qual do dae no caso aqui é o ser
humano do lado gato do outro que você
iria atropelar
só que essa situação é mais simples ele
chega ponto de situações de colocar é
crianças mulheres grávidas dentro do
carro e essa decisão começa a ficar
extremamente difícil para nós seres
humanos à conclusão que ele pegou
é que existem algumas preferências aí
pra manter ou não manter as pessoas é é
não não serem atropelados então a
criança é foi quase uma unanimidade não
não não devemos atropelar as crianças né
e os animais coitados não estão sendo
tão privilegiado sair nessa decisão mas
a questão toda é que isso não é tão
simples assim
os resultados variam de país para país
em países em que essa s gráfica é
diferente é uma média geral a e quando a
gente entra numa questão até um pouco
mais delicada se vocês souberem já devem
ter ouvido falar do crédito social é que
a china está querendo criar onde as
pessoas têm um hit ela tem um uma uma
pontuação então se você faz algo bom se
ganha pontos e faz algo ruim se perde
ponto e você tem um valor do quanto você
é importante para a sociedade o que
impede o governo chinês obrigar que os
carros autônomos decidam o que ele vai
fazer com relação é usando esse crédito
social ea gente começa a esbarrar em
questões éticas extremamente
preocupantes quando a gente fala que o
sistema de inteligência do céu vai
aprender com o ser humano
a gente cai nisso aqui é difícil
inteligentes baias ou o viés da
inteligência artificial
vocês devem falar mas é trivial eu não
percebo isso né não é uma coisa ainda
assim tão complexa
bom vou contar alguns algumas coisas que
a gente já sabe o que aconteceu com o
uso da inteligência artificial
ela já aprendeu que o o sexo masculino
programa melhor que o sexo feminino
ele fala isso ele prefere contratar é ea
ordem e quando a gente fala que
inteligência oficial estátuta decidindo
e vai tomar algumas decisões
ele vai escolher quem ele emprega quem
emprega quem entra na empresa irá
oferecer crédito bancário e coisas assim
ele aprende a que o joão o programa
melhor que a maria
nós temos um problema que não é fácil de
solucionar devem outro caso o tem na
literatura você encontra de que ele
aprendeu que as pessoas negras
nelas têm elas pagam elas têm mais
dificuldade para pagar sua dívida do que
as pessoas brancas
aí você começa a na questão de racismo
tem a gente acha que isso tá longe da
gente né
mas se você pegar e o google tradutor
ele já faz isso
se você escrever lá vocês podem fazer se
um celular de você sou eu têxteis hoje
de manhã ainda tava assim se você
colocar lá doctor ele vai escrever
médica e médico
ok é o que ele deveria realmente fazer
as empresas google ibm e outras mais
estão é fazendo um esforço enorme para
tentar resolver o problema mas se você
escrever lá de doctor doctor do kelvin
de peixe
aí ele já decide se é o sexo masculino
ou feminino e descreve o médico cuida do
paciente é você falar escolher um
aleatório não é bom mas se põe no ar se
ele escreve a enfermeira cuida do
paciente parece uma coisa boba mas na
hora em que a inteligência artificial
vai tomar decisões dentro de uma empresa
ou sem inteligência só vai começar a
decidir a nossa vida ou tomar decisões
importantes na nossa vida
isso começa a fazer a diferença e
trabalhar com isso é extremamente
complicado
então hoje os pesquisadores na área de
athens isso pra enfrentar
se nós queremos tudo aquilo que eu
comentei que eu quero que a inteligência
social cuida da minha vida que eu quero
que a inteligência artificial desenvolva
a selar ela ela permita uma vida melhor
pra mim ela consegue cuidar da minha
agenda cuidar da minha saúde ela
consegue decidir coisas importantes na
minha vida ela não pode agir dessa forma
há muitas empresas vêm colhendo
resultados semelhantes como esse
então se vocês procurarem na internet
vocês vão encontrar muita coisa assim em
inteligência artificial está tomando
decisões que tenham determinado viés de
quem é a culpa
se a gente for para analisar a
responsabilidade disso é de quem fez o
robô quem fez a inteligência artificial
ou é de quem é o dono ou utiliza a
inteligência artificial na verdade ea
não é a culpada por isso ela está
aprendendo como aos seres humanos
e aí vem um ponto interessante nessa
discussão toda é o governo alemão tá
decidindo algumas leis e está definindo
algumas leis onde se o carro autônomo
machucar alguém
a responsabilidade da empresa que fez o
carro é bem isso parece até razoável mas
se a gente entender isso por um robô
você comprou está na sua casa está
aprendendo com você e esse robô agem de
uma forma racista por exemplo você vai
comprar a empresa que fez o robô ou a
pessoa que ensinou o robô daquela forma
a legislação está preparada para isso
ainda há gente que ocupa a empresa que
faz o robô que faz o carro é a parte
mais fácil de todo esse processo é um
exemplo que a gente pode dar e com
relação a isso é se um adulto comete um
ato ilícito você vai culpar os pais
aí você fala na onde já é adulto ele já
aprendeu bastante ele já toma ele ele já
é responsável pela vida dele
bom o robô também depois de um certo
tempo de aprendizado ele é responsável
pelos seus atos ea gente não está
preparado pra isso a legislação não
cuida disso ea gente passa a fazer o
caminho mais simples que é vamos culpar
quem fez aí a então aí a tem um problema
muito sério pela frente
se a gente quer uma vida melhor se a
gente quer que a inteligência artificial
cuida da gente se a gente quer que a
inteligência dos eua tome decisões
melhor
ora se transforma em nossa sociedade nós
vamos ter que enfrentar isso é bom e aí
surge uma coisa muito interessante que é
novas a novas profissões aqui
particularmente para mim faz todo
sentido é o psicólogo de robôs ou
psicólogo da inteligência artificial
ela vai aprender coisas que você não
quer que ela aprenda
isso acontece com o ser humano quando
você tem algum trauma alguma coisa você
quer esquecer você vai no psicólogo só
conversa com você o que ele está fazendo
é tentar pagar parte da sua memória e
manter a outra não tem que fazer a mesma
coisa com os nossos robôs e com
inteligência artificial
vamos ter que sentar lá do nosso lado
imagina você para o robozinho robozinho
começa a fazer pergunta pra ele ele fala
errado não é isso aí se desliga ele vai
lá no programa mexe para tentar apagar
aquela informação isso não é trivial
para alguns de vocês é que já teve
contato com redes neurais de plano e
várias técnicas de ar
você sabe que o conhecimento está
embutida em um monte de números e você
não consegue decidir aonde está o
problema
só que eu não posso apagar a memória
inteira do robô
imagina 18 anos aprendendo e se
desenvolvendo e eu vou lá simplesmente
apaga tudo começa do zero
então essa profissão é uma profissão que
vai surgir e vai ser extremamente
importante para o desenvolvimento da
inteligência artificial no futuro
bom a gente finalizar uma coisa a gente
sempre comenta é dentro da área daí a é
que tudo isso depende da gente
somos nós que vamos levar aguiar isso
pro futuro somos nós seres humanos
usando a inteligência natural que vai
conseguir guiar como e até onde a
inteligência artificial pode chegar
então embora a gente quer atender toda
aquela as expectativas
a gente quer que a inteligência
artificial faz um monte de coisa
não ela não vai fazer se a gente não
cuidar desses problemas
e esse problema passa necessariamente
pelos nossos problemas
então nós vamos ter q
iná a iaa ser diferente da gente pode
ser um obstáculo intransponível
mas ele é necessário ser enfrentado ok
bom futuro a todos
[Aplausos]